pendant deux mois les rues se sont
vidées dans le désert des villes confiné
on les a remarqués
enfin ils sont chauffeurs de bus primeur
éboueurs ça va ou encore caissière il ya
des clients qui arrivent ici merci des
tra la la c'est de venir travailler
le confinement n'a pas changé leur vie
il continue de sortir travailler tous
les jours c'est parti en espérant ne pas
croiser le grenat virus j'ai pas la
psychose de dire attention c'est
dangereux
est ce que je fais tout alors je pense
pas
il était invisible on les appelle
désormais les héros il continue par
nécessité ou comme une évidence
moi j'estime que c'est mon devoir
quand j'ai des gens on va dire un sens
utile pour la lutte contre le communisme
il s'appelle khatib nordine mary et
jacqueline à nous les avons suivis le
ton d'une journée de travail en plein
confinement
[Musique]
c'est bon
départ pour enregister équipe et j'ai
plus qu'à prendre mes gants dans le
camion
c'est une boîte de gand conçu pour c'est
marie qui se lève la première il est à
peine trois heures la voici déjà sur la
route
marie et primeurs elle achète des fruits
et légumes pour les revendre depuis le
17 mars elle fait partie de cette armée
de l'ombre qui ravitaillent les français
en région parisienne
tout commence toujours à rungis
[Musique]
bon
marie vient ici depuis trente ans en ces
temps de coronavirus la journée commence
comme d'habitude ou presque
thé café du matin je me suis levée à
minuit et demi oui j'ai déjà bouche
muller c'est un petit peu un petit peu
bon on met pas de rouge à lèvres
maintenance à sarlat
non il ya beaucoup de monde vous allez
voir
l'aïd et au jeu bientôt pour avoir une
place justement parce qu'à placer notre
otage je peux pas me garer donc voilà
maintenant j'ai plus qu'un camion
d'habitude je vis avec deux camions mais
bon c'est compliqué vous allez voir pour
avoir la marchandise et tous et plus
choisis pas nous prépare les commandes
donc voilà vous allez voir c'est
compliqué il ya des barrières
une grande partie de la france est un
arrêt par un gif le plus grand marché du
monde est en pleine activité
il faut bien nourrir les français
confiné il y a bien sûr quelques signes
de la crise les masques les barrières
bonjour on ne touche plus les produits
on ne choisit plus sa marchandise on
n'avait pas tout ça mais ce qui change
surtout ce sont les prix ils se sont
envolés
un euro cinquante à peu près pourront
plus du kilo de certains articles
bon on n'a pas le choix 9 euros et le
melon 6 ça se mettre ça à mes clients en
extra voilà concrètement le travail en
lui-même il a un petit peu changé mais
s'ils n'ont pas toujours autant le
marché qui sont fermés les magasins
bosse beaucoup plus mais finalement ça
fait la balance et on boit sautant et
juste le nombre des marchandises un gros
problème par un provisionnement tout ce
qu'il a mentionné spar a vu ça c'est un
gros souci je suis fait que tout ce qui
est par bateau les prix augmentent que
les produits qu'ils sont
on va dire
ce qui devient rare et cher d'habitude
mari dans sur les marchés et au
restaurant des lieux qui sont désormais
fermés alors évidemment elle achète
beaucoup moins presque au détail
voilà de patates douces la moins chère
c'est 220
bon ben moi ça c'est pas grave une une
on fait un peu drôle aussi de trois
choristes et tous mes bons membres
c'est fini donc avant d'acheter beaucoup
des grans des quinze sacs de pommes de
terre et touché beaucoup de quantité
mais bon j'ai lu le savent donc voilà on
n'a que ça revienne à la normale mais
bon voilà merci les titres
et puisque ses clients ne peuvent plus
venir à elle c'est elle qui va aller
chez eux tous ses cageots vont être
livrés à domicile
marie à réinventer son métier
l'appel totalement complètement huawei
et encore j'ai tout de suite plombée
savait tout de suite dit aux gens que je
moi pour aller d'une rue marie va
assurer seul sa tournée elle a dû mettre
ses deux salariés au chômage partiel
[Musique]
le deuxième à se lever c'est nordine il
est 4 heures
argenteuil lors de la première tournée
la ville dort encore quand nordine prend
les commandes de son camion
il est chauffeur reaper autrement dit
éboueurs j'avais pas au dépôt 3h30 je ne
sais pas chaque matin il lui donne
de produits pour les résidents et le
produit pour un fût difficile
des camions
voilà élégant ni masque
[Musique]
unima le premier tour 2007
aurélia noidans dérouille la clio 3
heures sur la police nous la police
matin l'action d'autres
et les rois du petit matin du boulot
jamais ils n'ont votants de poubelles
aligner les français sont chez eux toute
la journée alors les déchets
s'accumulent
c'est mathématique
[Musique]
énorme
tous ces sacs éventrés sont autant de
menaces le coronavirus peut s'y trouver
on essaye dépendantes râpé mais bon si
on l'a on love tonight travaillent pas
ils n'ont donc peut m'arriver
la peur
vous pensez comme moi la surnature on
attend
bon on prend des risques merco bon
travail on n'a pas le choix il faudra
macho que j'eusse par terre les gens
voient là une maîtrise lui coupe est
partout
voilà même pas sa coupelle dix fois on
trouve
partout pro le pavillon bleu nordine n'a
jamais voulu rester chez lui qui
ramassera les ordures alors il se
protège
et puis il y à tous ces petits mots qui
pousse comme par magie sur les poubelles
des remerciements des dessins
passez pas par des pavés des maisons
tout seuls
mon cas c'est ma fille merci beaucoup
visuel des agents qui travaillent pour
nous sur les pistes
et nordine ne se fait plus klaxonner
depuis le confinement le regard sur son
métier a changé mais pour combien de
temps
[Musique]
à 7 heures paris s'éveille seller
délivrerait d employé de supérette
ils ont intégré de nouveaux gestes pour
se protéger presque une routine
le directeur du magasin doit veiller sur
ses salariés et au respect des règles de
distanciation par les clients derrière
son rideau de plastique voici jacqueline
à si on lui avait montré ce décor il ya
deux mois elle n'y aurais jamais cru
nécessaire
oui c'est très important mais c'est dans
ce sens qu'ils sont ceux qui répondent
avec tout ça
malgré le mince élégant et ça ça fait se
sent mieux gérer les lois
les pertes
jacques lina est protégé derrière son
écran de plastique et pourtant jamais
les clients n'ont fait autant attention
à elle
oui moi je
sinon comment on fera que nourrir mais
non bien fait avec talent c'est très
symbolique et sympathique pour vous oui
oui il a des clients qui n'utilisent
merci d'être l'adversaire travail et sa
triplette sarsat remettre les caméras
c'est un grand bonjour ça va quand on
voit des gens qui qui prennent des
risques qui travailleurs là j'essaye de
parler que des assistés les aînés d'être
gentil non mais elles sont plus exposées
que nous hein
nadeau ce client a repéré le micro de
lcp
il en profite pour faire passer un
message députés ils sont souvent un peu
loin ils veulent revenir à l'assemblée
c'est bon signe volta démocratie
s'applique comme s'applique dans le bon
sens vous à vis des gens payés mieux ces
gens là par exemple la polo d'une
caissière c'est tout sauf au centre où
ils veulent juste faire peur aux accords
qu'elle parce que face à la quête que ce
soit fait vite et tout ça et n'ont
jamais vraiment comment valoriser le une
caissière en temps normal
après rungis marie est rentrée chez elle
à première vue on pourrait croire
qu'elle joue à la marchande tout seul
dans son garage
et miss est stable avec sa balance du
marché mon terminal est en charge toute
la nuit pour quoi que les gens payent
avec la carte bleue en fait mary prépare
les commandes ses clients l'ont tapé la
veille
ils lui ont fait une liste précise comme
sur le marché elle prépare
minutieusement chaque panier
elle est aux petits soins j'aime bien
enfin que les gens et voilà ils
choisissent ce qu'ils veulent quand même
oui quand je vais au travail là je pense
à bennwihr sap tous les traits communs
et je me dis bon le banquier les comptes
encore comme ça rentre un type mari a
tout juste de quoi payer ses charges
mais pas assez pour se verser un salaire
alors elle vit sur ses réserves fait
partie
on va dans le 14e arrondissement rue de
la gaîté marie a intégré les gestes
barrière je n'ai pas très conviviale
mais il faut vivre avec les gens ils
font très attention même si me voit il
reste loin ils ont très peur quand maman
je laisse les courses par terre après
ils les prennent voilà comment ça va
dessus mais c'est bien d'avoir les bons
gestes je suis contente je me dis que
cette façon il faut les garder un
j'ai pas la psychose de dire attention
c'est dangereux à ce que je fais est ou
non j'y pense pas j'essaye de positiver
marie connaît de près les dangers du
coronavirus elle a perdu une tente de la
maladie et sa fille qui travaille à
l'hôpital l'a attrapé mais elle n'a
jamais pensé à rester chez elle alors
qu'elle est en rémission d'un cancer est
une pathologie
j'ai un cancer il faut faire quand même
attention elle maigrit savait pas dire
non vie ont bien travaillé
non
non non parce que quand j'étais très
très malade j'ai toujours été travaillée
en fin de compte
je faisais mes chimie où j'allais faire
mes achats avant les fesses j'allais
faire massimo après donc voila quoi je
vais à ces battantes quand je peux le
faire je le fais
pour cette livraison direction le
boulevard edgar quinet avec une émotion
particulière et beaucoup de nostalgie
marie est à quelques pas seulement de
son emplacement sur le marché
je suis juste devant le café l'important
les brasseries les dessins pinocchio cd
brasserie que je sers d'habitude très
bon client et que l'âge et plus puisque
c'est fermer quoi ça nous fait drôle de
passer devant ah oui ouais ouais
franchement oui c'est tellement
l'habitude d'animer et tous les chaises
sont sortis à les gens qui doivent déjà
leur petit café quand il fait beau comme
ça en terrasse déjà donc oui c'est sûr
que ça fait profite bien voilà merci
beaucoup
havas est passé des choses fragiles
d'accord auquel vont retrouver niamey et
je vous dis petit mentalement
si elle n'existait pas il faudrait
l'inventer
[Musique]
marie doit déjà reprendre la route
une vingtaine de clients l'attendent
souvent de très fidèle et connaissances
qui sont presque devenus des amis
c'est une science qui vient
régulièrement sans marcher il a appelé
le marché revienne bonjour en vis à vis
à vis et regarder voilà les années j'ai
pas le temps d un chauffe eau paris
donc ça c'est pour les méchants pour qui
j'ai fait quelques coups reçus
voilà il ya le ticket vouloir de moi et
ça c'est le vôtre qui vaut mieux d'avoir
ce système si la meilleure vague
marchand de primeurs du marché ou jouer
toutes les semaines
mise en place de ce service est
merveilleux heureusement qu'elle est là
parce que j'ai décidé moi les fruits et
légumes des grandes surfaces
par ailleurs c'est joli ça pas debout
voilà il faut faire travailler tous les
producteurs
mettez commerçants voilà c'est fait
c'est bon vous voyez prendre le premier
est la carte
voilà merci on met pas de journée à vous
tous merci beaucoup
sous les masques on devine la chaleur
des souris j'aime rendre service aux
gens c'est non c'est dans moi c'est ça
s'explique pas voilà qui n'ont pas
d'inquiétude
non non je pense pas ça voilà je croise
les doigts quand je me dis j'ai
peut-être une bonne étoile
voilà
pendant sa tournée marie croiser tous
ces bus presque vide qui sillonne paris
et ses rues désertées
nous sommes allés à la rencontre de l'un
de ses chauffeurs khatib il a huit ans
de métier et comme jacqueline à il
n'aurait jamais imaginé ce cadre de
travail un bunker au tour de son poste
de conduite
il est totalement isolé s'élever entier
l'agression elle fait barrière quoi oui
c'est clair on est bien protégé plus le
masque juste et 8 pouces et un mètre de
distance
on est très bien protégé et son bus est
presque vide
khatib compte ses passagers sur les
doigts d'une main depuis le début de mon
service j'en ai pris quoi 3,4 pas plus
moi il y a quatre mois
khatib conduisait ce même dû cependant
les grèves un bus bondé
il avait dû faire face aux bousculades
au stress
le contraste est saisissant et cela lui
semble désormais bien loin
il n'a jamais arrêté de conduire son bus
et aujourd'hui il est encore plus
motivés qu'ils me remercie d'être là
parce que ils disent que grâce à lui
vont au travail par exemple tout à
l'heure j'ai pris des infirmières que
j'ai déposé à l'hôpital georges-pompidou
vous remercier d'être là et m'ont
remerciée pour les navettes vous ai pas
posé la question de venir travailler
pour 10 et des notes dans c'est normal
c'est normal vous posez la question par
exemple par exemple aux médecins aux
infirmières aux il se pose pas la
question ils risquent leur vie de tous
les jours moi j'estime que c'est mon
devoir de conduire les gens j'ai payé
pour ça et ça fait dans le plaisir tout
on va dire je me sens utile
pour la lutte contre le cancer
khatib transporte quelques personnes qui
vont au travail et aussi des personnes
fragiles bonjour jeu sans lui elle ne
pourrait pas se rendre à leurs
rendez-vous aujourd'hui j'aurais pas pu
marcher les chercheurs des matchs pour
les remercier ces gens avaient comme on
va vous voulez rire avant de son
collector je suis seul et demande dans
les tours là on n'a pas de balfour nan
je suis assis sur cloud y est j'ai les
larmes qui s'avéra chaque fois je ne
sais pas
[Musique]
argenteuil nordine fini sa tournée les
uns après les autres les camions rentrer
au dépôt quoi être lavés et désinfectés
et cet équipage a ramené un grand
panneau de remerciement peint par un
enfant de quartier comme un trophée une
récompense pour leur travail
avant le coronavirus il n'avait jamais
reçu de telles attentions
ici au dépôt nordine et les autres
partagent les petits mots les dessins
l'occasion de les immortaliser
surtout quand on leur dit vous êtes nos
héros ça fait plaisir pour nous tout le
monde pour tous les édiles et l'équipe
qui travaille à azur avant de rentrer
chez lui nordine se change pas question
de ramener des vêtements qu'ils
pourraient être touchés par le virus à
la maison et sur le pas de la porte il
enlève ses chaussures en deux mois c'est
devenu un automatisme depuis le
confinement sa femme s'inquiète pour lui
elle a peur qu'ils tombent malade alors
il la rassure et il partage avec elle ce
qu'il vit en tournée les remerciements
les encouragements il est fier de lui
montrer le dessin reçu aujourd'hui
donc c'est pas une éclaircie mais des
péquenots du reversement voilà lâché
cette enfant on dit que les nôtres
étaient les héros moi je dis bah oui
c'est comme des héros en fait un sont là
entre berling de pouvoir être l'aftm
quoi du bien qui enfant la
reconnaissance pour le métier de votre
mari
[Musique]
amusez-vous
pour tous la priorité c'est de protéger
leurs familles alors chez jacqueline a
aussi on a mis en place un nouveau
rituel david j je ne demande pas au
début il venait toujours vers moi donc
je vais stopper les noms ils ont compris
gens je rentre donc j'ai pas lavé des
plombs débarrasser mais à faire étape à
s'approcher
donc pendant que jacques il la passe par
la salle de bains et l'ina et dania
attendent patiemment
voilà c'est comme ça se passe alors moi
je voudrais travailler oui
ouais travail qu'abat forçant à frotter
cette phase arrêtée sur ton si je suis
bien protégé par mot voilà un fait peur
oui c'est bien protéger les pièces c'est
aussi et donc normalement je croise les
doigts jusqu'à rien
elin aida il me reste à la maison avec
leur papa il travaille dans la
restauration il est donc au chômage
partiel
c'est lui qui suit les devoirs et les
occupe une nouvelle complicité est née
avec ses filles et ensemble ils
redoublent d'attention pour jacqueline à
maman la commande et comme tu l'as dit
il on y va parce qu'en fait il ya eu une
histoire vis-à-vis de ça justement c'est
à dire qu'en fait à 20 heures tout le
monde applaudit non je dis ok vous
applaudissez pourquoi en fait si maman
c'est un héros si c'est une héroïne
c'est toi qui l'a c'est moi qui ai dit
hey rosetta 10 euros elle y
l'héroïne comme l'appellent ses filles
est payé au smic
elle devrait toucher la prime de 1000
euros pour les salariés exposés aux
coronavirus
mais après jacques lina a bien entendu
le président évoqué la revalorisation de
ces petits métiers aussi que notre pays
aujourd'hui tient tout entier sur des
femmes et des hommes que nos économies y
reconnaissent jacqueline à aimerait d'y
croire il faudra vraiment qu'il
reconnaisse après quoi le frappant la
balle de brouilleurs devient bon ça
tient qu'à lui par cali est un soutien
tout le monde danse est de reconnaître
un peu plus le travail décent dans les
plu à valeur et trois choses que jamais
été fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
avec demande il est l'heure de dire
merci aux soignants et à tous et
invisible comme jacqueline à khatib mari
ou nordine ces travailleurs de l'ombre
qui ont permis aux français de mener une
vie presque normale pendant ces longues
semaines de confinement
[Musique]
où
il vous